BERNIE GLASSMAN: So my name is
Bernie, born in Brooklyn, went
to undergraduate school in
aeronautical engineering.
I went to LA to work in
interplanetary work for a
while, but had a dual track.
I got involved in Zen studies.
I lived at a Zen center
with my wife and kids.
And I started teaching Zen in
1967, probably before many of
you were born.
Moved back to New York 1980s.
At McDonnell Douglas, I had
a Ph.D. in applied math.
I originally was, like I say,
interplanetary work, which is
dynamics, but then got
involved in software
validation.
In those early days, there was
really no way of knowing
whether software had bugs in it
or not, until they failed.
And of course we were putting
software in manned missions,
and nuclear reactors.
So some people had the good idea
that we should work on
figuring out whether the
software will work, and
especially given different
conditions.
There's so many different
initial conditions.
So I got involved in that field
for McDonnell Douglas
corporate-wide, which had plants
in LA and St. Louis.
But in 1980, I moved back to
New York, actually to the
Bronx, to a place called
Riverdale.
I started something called the
Zen Community of New York.
I was born about 75 years ago
in Brooklyn to a Jewish
Socialist family.
So in my blood I had social
activism as part of my DNA.
And when I moved back, I wanted
to teach Zen, but also
get involved in social
action things.
And I was particularly
interested in something that's
called mandala practice, a
holistic approach to social
action, where you look at five
different types of energies.
You look at spiritual energy,
training energy, social action
energy, livelihood energy,
and relationships energy.
And you try to cover
the gamut.
I decided to work in
homelessness in 1982.
And I looked at a city called
Yonkers, which many of you
probably know.
It's a little north of here, in
Westchester County, right
north of the Bronx.
And it had the highest per
capita homeless rate in the
country at that time.
And Westchester County was one
of the wealthiest counties in
the country at that time.
So it seemed like an interesting
place to look.
At it and I looked at
it holistically.
And so we started creating
housing.
But you need jobs in order
to not have the
housing become slums.
And since we were dealing with
a lot of single parent
families, you needed childcare
in order for them
to be able to work.
And then, because there's a lot
of drugs in their history,
you needed counseling work,
and family therapy work.
And then I was asked to get
involved with AIDS when it
first started becoming
a big deal.
And so I created housing for
folks with AIDS, and a health
center for HIV positive
people.
That's all going.
It's about 30 years
in progress.
And it's not as big as Google.
But it is doing good work.
And we brought some cookies
from the Greyston Bakery,
which has an interesting
hiring policy.
In fact, today, they have
an open hiring.
Their policy is when there are
openings, it's first come,
first serve.
We don't do any background
checks.
So we are hiring a lot of people
that have never worked
before, or their work
was dealing drugs.
And homeless people, a lot of
people with prison records--
probably everybody homeless
has prison records.
But we don't do any checking.
And then we break the workers
down into teams.
And of course everybody
in the team, they
all know each other.
They're all from the hood.
So if somebody comes in
to their team, and
they know the person.
And if they're paid
a certain amount.
If they overproduce, they
produce more, they split in
the profits.
So they have the incentive of
teaching the person who's
coming into their team to do
well if the person is there
just to get enough money to get
some drugs next week, then
that person won't do well.
And they will let go
of that person.
Buddhism--
Zen is just one school
of Buddhism.
Buddhism is about
experiencing the
interconnectedness of life.
The folks that we have, that
we take off the street and
have started work, most of them,
their interconnection
stops at their own body,
at themselves.
Coming through our teamwork,
they start seeing the
interconnectedness
of the group.
They may not think
of it that way.
But they are interested
in helping the
other people do well.
Because they see that
it affects them.
AUDIENCE: Do you also get teams
where the dynamic works
in reverse, and everyone
on the team is--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: We haven't.
But this teamwork thing has
only been in effect since
about 1990.
So in that short period of
history, we have not yet had a
case like that.
So that's pretty cool.
Anyway, having done that
work, I then am
feeling good about it.
And I travel around the world.
And I met other people doing
wonderful things.
I started getting involved
in volunteering
in different countries.
I worked with the untouchables
in India, in Africa, in Rwanda
with the sorrow and grief from
the 20 year genocide, in
Brazil, in Europe, Sri Lanka,
different places.
About 15 years ago I moved
to Santa Barbara.
And about a year before that I
had seen this movie that I
started off with, asking
about, called "The Big
Lebowski." I loved the movie.
Now, I don't know if you have to
be a New York Jew to really
love the movie.
I don't think so, because it
became quite a cult movie.
And of course there's only one
guy in that movie that really
claims to be Jewish.
And that's John Goodman,
who married a Jew.
Anyway, I don't want to spoil
it for the two of you who
haven't seen it.
But The Dude is a very
interesting character.
And the lines, for
me, were very
interesting in that movie.
And when I met Jeff Bridges--
who plays The Dude--
15 years ago, what I was a
little surprised about was
that he looked just like
The Dude and acted
just like The Dude.
And in fact, the clothes that he
wore in the movie "The Big
Lebowski" are his own clothes.
He dresses like that
around the house.
And he has threatened to his
wife to dress like that when
he goes doing interviews,
and whatever.
And she says, you can't
do it, Jeff.
They've been married 35 years.
And he listens to her.
But anyway, I was very
impressed with the
lines in the movie.
And I told him that The Dude
in the movie acts like an
enlightened person.
For me, everybody
is enlightened.
But there are depths
of enlightenment.
And enlightenment is a
realization of the
interconnectedness of life.
And as you go deeper and deeper
in that, and you find
that everything is
interconnected, then when
things come up, you may go
berserk, but not for long.
You bounce back quicker
and quicker as you
go deeper and deeper.
Because you just grok that
it's all one thing, man.
So if something is happening,
that's what's happening.
What are you going to
go crazy about it?
You're going to work with it.
You're going to take those
new ingredients and do
the best you can.
And it keeps going.
So he started studying
with me Zen.
He'd already been meditating
on his own.
And we studied, been studying
now 15 years.
And then about a year and a half
ago, I said, you want to
do a book together?
And we went away for
four days, to a
house he has in Montana.
And we chatted.
And it was all taped, videoed,
then transcribed, then edited.
Then it came out in January as
a book called "The Dude and
the Zen Master."
That's a little flashback
on it all.
And now I want to open
to questions.
Some of the things that people
who know about me want to ask,
I'll just throw them out before
your questions, is
about 25 years ago, before I
started getting very heavily
involved in doing work for the
homeless, I went to live in
the streets.
And I invited some people
to come with me.
About 18 came on that first
street retreat.
And there have been street
retreats happening ever since.
I started in New York.
And there are street retreats
happening in
New York every year.
Generally in the Bowery
is where they start,
drift around a little.
Now there's street retreats
happening around the world,
led by different people.
I just did probably my
last street retreat a
year and a half ago.
I'm getting a little old.
It rained the full--
that was four days.
Most of retreats I've
done are seven days.
18 years ago I started an annual
retreat at Auschwitz.
I call it bearing witness
retreats.
And that one is dealing with
the issues of diversity and
how we treat others.
And so it's purposely structured
so that there are
people from many countries, many
religions, many cultures.
There are survive that come,
children of survivors,
grandchildren of survivors.
There are children and
grandchildren of SS people who
ran the camps.
There are Palestinians and
Israelis that come.
There are Native Americans that
have come, because they
want to do a similar retreat
in the Black Hills.
And Rwandans have come, because
we are scheduling for
the 20th anniversary of that
genocide, a retreat in Rwanda,
bringing together the Hutus and
the Tutsis and the people
from the Congo and Uganda, and
people from Belgium and France
that were huge factors
in all of that
stuff, Germany and Poland.
So those are called bearing
witness retreats.
And I talk about all that kind
of stuff in the book.
I've written other books.
I've written a book called
"Bearing Witness." And this
model for Greyston, the model
for working with the homeless,
I'm trying to replicate that in
an Arab city in Israel that
would employee Israeli
Palestinians, Israeli Jews,
and West Bank Palestinians that
would get work permits.
Because a wall goes through the
city that we're planning
to put that in.
So it's that kind of
stuff that I do.
Now, questions.
AUDIENCE: When you run your
bakery, you have this process,
or no process, no background
checks, no--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: We call
it open hiring.
AUDIENCE: Open hiring, so what
is the philosophy behind that?
What it is about the checks that
happen in a lot of other
jobs that you think--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Well,
it's fear, I think.
I think people are afraid of
hiring potential violent
people, or no-good people.
It's stereotyping, profiling,
and fear.
I think all of those
factors go into it.
And Zen is about experiencing
things, not
holding on to you concepts.
Have a lot of ideas, and stuff
like that, but not
attaching to those.
Zen is a practice of trying to
let go of those attachments to
be able to see things as they
are, not as we think they are.
That's is what went into the
idea of open hiring, that we
were going to go by the
experience of how they worked,
rather than what their
background stuff said they
were, and what our
prototypes were.
So for example, at that time,
and probably still, many
people have a stereotype that
homeless people are no good,
or they're inferior to others.
And in fact, as borne out by
if you're on the streets,
you'll find that most people
seeing us, seeing a homeless
person, a street person, will
either across the street or
avert their eyes.
They don't want to look.
There's a lot--
at my age or you forget what
you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: Have you
tried replicating
that in other places?
Is there something special
about here that would be
difficult to replicate
elsewhere?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: No.
As I say, I'm trying to
replicate it now in Israel.
It's studied.
The model is studied.
It's interesting.
The model is a for profit not
for profit spiritual model the
spirituality of the model is
that as a Zen teacher, when I
did this, I was hoping that the
people not only would get
jobs, but would start
interconnecting with others,
and then with the
bigger world.
Because that's the role of the
Zen teacher, is to help people
learn about the
interconnectedness of life.
The spiritual part, Greyston
as a model, as a not for
profit for profit, what is
called nowadays, for the last
10 years probably, social
entrepreneurship, that is
being taught in many business
schools, as you know.
And Greyston is a model
that is studied in
many business schools.
It's studying at Wharton, at
Harvard, at Yale, at Columbia,
at Stanford.
But they don't incorporate
this spiritual
component of it.
Which, if you went to Greyston,
and you walked in,
you would feel.
You feel something different
going on.
Now we don't have [INAUDIBLE]
troops, which I
think is a big lack.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any formal
meditation training offered?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: No.
Well, it's offered, but not--
there is a mentioned there is
a Zen meditation hall there.
And now, for example, I come
once a month to volunteer.
I come down there
once a month.
Because we have a program, which
my wife and I started,
even with Zen students before
bringing it to Greyston,
called the Pathmaking Program.
Which, this same holistic
model, we
introduce to your life.
We would sit down, and talk
about what's your interest, in
terms of spirituality?
What's your interest, in terms
of work, in terms of study, in
terms of service in the
community, in terms of
relationships?
And then next year, six months
later, we look how you're
doing along those, if you
want change a path.
We call it pathmaking.
And every employee has a path
that they set up for
themselves with a woman who's in
charge of pathmaking work.
And Paco here is on the board.
And he's co-chair of the
pathmaking committee.
It's a big piece of what
Greyston is about.
That comes from the spiritual
background.
That's not part of the
model of that study.
And yet it's a key part
of that model.
Obviously there are other not
for profit for profit
integrations.
But I don't think there's
something quite like Greyston.
And there should be, I think.
Because it works.
And I've got 30 years
of proof to that.
Theoretically, it should
be duplicated.
AUDIENCE: Your limit with
homeless was seven days among
other people.
Do you think this draws
attention to homeless awareness?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: No, except
for the people
that went on it.
For the people who've been
on the street retreat--
and now there are thousands--
it changed forever how
they would deal
with homeless people.
Because, what do you think is
the biggest thing that a
person feels when they go
to live on the street?
I'll tell you what the things
are that they think about
before they go to live
on the street.
And you would probably
associate.
They're concerned
about violence,
abuse, maybe being raped.
They're concerned about
being hungry.
That's probably the
biggest concerns.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Huh?
Being sick.
I've never had anybody
have that concern.
But that would be yours.
What do you think is the biggest
thing that they find
that has affected them when
they're finished?
AUDIENCE: Shame?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Shame.
Loss of dignity.
People not looking at them.
Middle class and upper class
folks are not so used to
people not wanting to look
at them, ignore them.
From then on, people who have
gone on the streets tend to
ask a homeless person,
how are you?
What's your name?
And they don't make contact.
It's hard not to make contact
when you've--
AUDIENCE: How about begging?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Well, I have a
certain rules when you come
on the streets with me.
And one of them is that you
can't bring any money, and
that you have to beg.
Now there is enough
food to get.
Food is not an issue.
There's plenty of food
in the streets.
There's all kinds of ways
that it's being offered.
Bathrooms is a little harder.
And resting is hard.
But I insist on begging, because
that's something that
most people are not
to used to.
And my very first street
retreat, for example, I
require that you raise $1,000
for every day you came with me
on the streets.
And that you couldn't
use your own money.
And you had to ask friends
and relatives or whoever.
And there was one man, it was
a very wealthy man who came.
And he said, Bernie, I just
want to pay the $5,000.
And I said, no.
You can't do that.
You have to ask.
He says I can't ask my
friends for money to
go live on the street.
All his friends were
wealthy friends.
But that experience of raising
that money initially is the
kind of experience when you go
out on the streets and beg.
People think you're crazy.
Or can't you work.
They think very negatively
of you.
Whereas in India, there could
be many holy men that that's
how they live their
whole life, for
instance, through begging.
Begging turns out to be--
that's why Paco mentioned it--
it happens to be a big factor
that changes people.
It also gets people to see
that they can live in any
circumstances, that they're not
depends and on all of the
money they think they
need to have.
You can live, and be very free
in the moment, with nothing.
Because you have everything.
We the museums free, art.
You have the parks.
You have everything.
It's all out there.
It's all out here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In your experience,
can you stack or rank the best
ways to reach enlightenment?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: I defined
enlightenment as the
experience of the
interconnectedness of life.
There are depths of different
degrees of enlightenment.
The way you can tell the degree,
the depth to which a
person has achieved
enlightenment is how they
serve others.
We're all very used to
servicing ourselves.
When you're hungry,
you get food.
You go to a gym to get
in better shape.
You get a job to make
money, to do things.
You may read books about
enlightenment, or whatever.
We do a lot of things in
terms of ourselves.
That means that you are
enlightened to the degree of
knowing that you are
all interconnected.
In fact, you don't even
think about it.
You act that way.
When you're hungry, your hands
bring food to the mouth.
If you're bleeding,
the hand takes
care of what's happening.
It doesn't think about whether
I should do it or not do it.
Some women, when they give
birth, don't feel a separation
between them and the child.
The child does some colicky
thing, or something, and the
mother does something
immediately.
It's not a discussion of whether
to do it or not do it.
Am I trained enough?
They are enlightened to the
level of them and their child.
And with time, they lose that.
And the child becomes a separate
thing than them.
But it could be the same.
In my experience, the Dalai
Lama is serving the world.
So his degree of enlightenment
is the depth of the world.
So you already ready enlightened
to the degree of
take of taking care
of yourself.
From my definition, what would
be the easiest way of
learning, of deepening that
experience, of taking care of
others, is to serve others.
It can go the other
way around.
And in the world of Zen, the
majority of teaching is
teaching that through meditation
you will learn.
Your attachments will fall away,
and so that you will
experience this
interconnectedness.
I've been a pioneer in proposing
that through social
action you can deepen
that experience.
Which to me makes sense,
when you say it.
And of course, you're
doing some good
things at the same time.
I love to sit.
I sit every day.
It doesn't mean you
don't meditate.
But I would say that no matter
what your life is like, if you
could spend some time serving
others, that will help.
That would be my approach.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
You had mentioned you were an
aeronautical engineer, had a
career in the math field.
I'm curious about the transition
from that into a
very social role.
And I'm not sure I have a
specific question, just in
terms of how you decided to
make that transition, what
fears or obstacles you face,
what things turned out to be
less problematic than
you expected?
How was that transition
for you?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: For me
it was no sweat, man.
I got interested
in Zen in 1958.
I was a junior in undergraduate
school.
Then I got a job.
In '60 moved to California, was
in the aerospace industry.
But I was hooked into
Zen at that time.
was
It Turns out when I was 11, 12,
I had started a whole book
of arguments that I came across
for and against the
existence of God, through
literature, through science.
I was brought up in a socialist
family, not a
religious family.
But somehow I had that kind
of spiritual bent.
When I went to work, I was
already sitting and working.
And then I left there for two
years of work to go to Israel,
to explore.
I'd read about a spiritual
kibbutz there,
and I wanted to explore.
I didn't find what I wanted.
Israel was too macho for me.
And I came back.
I met my wife there.
And a little after we came
back and married, she got
involved in war resistance
league, helping people stay
out of the Vietnam War.
Our house was--
I was working in the
aerospace industry.
And part of the company
I was working
for was making missiles.
And we were working keeping
folks out of the draft.
And working with people that
were part of that movement,
that wanted to go into the
courts to fight the system.
That organization started by
a guy named David Harris.
He and Joan Baez got married.
This may be all old timers.
AUDIENCE: Having trouble
following the--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: But
at any rate, I had
dual lives going in.
And at McDonnell Douglas, I they
knew I was in Zen, and a
Zen teacher.
And it was OK for me to take
a week off every month, two
hours every day, come in one
hour later and leave one hour
earlier to take off a week every
month to do a retreat.
And then they actually appointed
me as the creativity
guru, corporate-wide because
of my Zen background.
I had these mutual paths.
And it was never a problem.
It was cool with everybody.
It was cool with me.
I didn't have difficulties.
AUDIENCE: Are you still
interested in technology and
engineering, and stuff
like that?
Or is one path really
dominated now?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: No.
I'm still interested.
It's not as heavy, and
not in everything.
I'm interested in new
developments in
the computer world.
I'm interested in chaos stuff.
My math wasn't, actually.
I was before the chaos.
But that interested me.
I follow up on some
of that, kind of.
I had a student who was one of
the discoverers, or one of the
original thinkers on
string theory.
And he died, early age,
of diabetes, somehow.
This was when I was back in LA,
when I didn't really know.
All I knew is it was a
new kind of thing.
I don't know if any of you
know Fritz Kopper?
Well, this fellow, Joel
and Fritz were very--
Frans Kopper.
Or it was it Fritz?
They worked together at
the Bern in Geneva.
Kopper wrote a book.
And Joel had him send it
to me for comments.
So this is way, way back.
And then we did a workshop
together on Dogen and being
time, and his new physics.
That kind of stuff I have
a general interest.
I do not--
I will have to admit--
I do not read Buddhist books.
They seem to be repeating the
same stuff over and over.
I like new stuff.
AUDIENCE: So at one
point you did?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: I read a
lot of Buddhist stuff.
And then at some point
I stopped.
It felt like I was repetition.
AUDIENCE: What do you read?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Detective
stories, I love detective
stories, especially Norwegian
and Sweden.
They have some great
writers there.
AUDIENCE: What drew you to Zen,
as opposed to any of the
other schools?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: I read
about it in 1958.
It was the first time
I heard about it.
And it felt like home.
What I read about was talking
about the interconnectedness
of life, and the wonders
of life.
And most of my experience with
religions and other things was
really folks separating
themselves, and talking about
how one's better
than the other.
There was a certain interest in
exploring mystical things.
And being Jewish, I
looked into the
Hasidic ways, Kabbalah.
But the discrimination between
men and women was
too huge for me.
I couldn't get into that.
And Buddhism had this appeal,
to me, of we're all
interconnected in this world.
A little different, but it's
the kind of thing I'd been
talking about.
That was a very appealing
to me.
And I want to experience that.
Because I didn't feel Common
in most of the
religions of groups.
And then later, on I got very
involved in interfaith work.
And I read about that
kind of thinking in
almost every religion.
I've been to Catholic
monasteries.
I've studied the [INAUDIBLE].
I've taken hand as a Sufi.
I've certainly had
Jewish training.
And I am a little unusual.
I have 40 dharma successors.
That is, there's 40 people that
I have empowered to be
Zen teachers.
Some of them are Catholic
priests.
Some of them are
Catholic nuns.
Some of them are Sufi sheikhs.
Some of them are rabbis.
It's a wide range.
It's more like an interfaith
Zen then
strictly a Buddhist Zen.
Because they still work
in those professions.
And in fact, one
of the rabbis--
I don't know how many here are
Jewish-- you know Yom Kippur?
That's the holiest
day in Judaism.
It's a day of fasting.
He's Israeli.
His family is six generations
Israeli.
He leads a street retreat on Yom
Kippur in the poorest part
of Tel Aviv, a very dangerous
part of Tel Aviv
AUDIENCE: So you say that
there's this interfaith
dialogue in all religion.
Where do you think
that gets lost?
You said that when you studied
other religions, you didn't
see that divide.
But then you also said that you
see an interfaith dialogue
at the core of a lot
of religions.
So where do you think
that fits?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Well, in
Buddhism, it's the main.
It's the main thrust.
The word Buddha means
awakened one.
And awaken to what?
Awakened to the
interconnectedness of life.
And we call that experience
enlightenment.
All of Buddhism is about that.
And there are many schools
of Buddhism.
And there are different schools
trying to answer your
question, what's the best way of
getting that enlightenment
experience and deepening it?
There's many different ways--
visualizations, meditations,
chanting.
I push social engagement.
In the Hindu world, karma
yoga is a common thing.
Karma yoga is that
kind of spiritual
life, serving others.
We don't have that
in Buddhism.
We don't have a school that's
equivalent to karma yoga.
Now there are some in Japan.
But not yet in this country.
And in this country, I'm
probably the one that's--
my family is called
Zen peacemakers.
And there are about
140 Zen peacemaker
groups around the world.
And theoretically they're
supposed to be interested in
also helping others.
But the mainstream of
Buddhism was this
interconnectedness of life.
And the other traditions have
felt like those were
marginalized aspects,
one would say
the mystical aspects.
But the mainstream folks in
those religions probably never
heard of it, even though we
might look at them as some--
for example, in Islam, Rumi--
most people have
heard of Rumi.
And Rumi talks that way.
But yet it's not quite
made mainstream.
AUDIENCE: So bringing it back
to homelessness, can you
elaborate on the connection
between Zen and homelessness?
Can the homeless
learn from Zen?
Can they become Zen?
What's your ultimate
focus there?
Have you learned anything about
the homeless beyond you
shared already that most
people don't really
understand?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Well, one of
the fascinating things to me
is that once a year, when I
was there during the early
days, once a month we had a date
called mandala day, in
which we brought everybody
together.
Which meant we had to
close the childcare.
We had to close all the things
we were doing, for that day.
And we would bring everybody
together.
And we had different exercises
about interconnecting each
other, different things.
Now, once a year, there's
something called mandala day.
And the 170 or 180 people
come together.
And they have to shut
the child care.
That's a big deal.
Shut the bakery.
The bakery is making about $10
million a year now, employing
about 80 people.
It does the chocolate fudge
brownies for Ben and Jerry's
Chocolate Fudge Brownie
Ice Cream and Yogurt.
That's its biggest customer.
AUDIENCE: If we buy Ben and
Jerry's Chocolate Fudge ice
cream, we're supporting--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Exactly.
And it says so on the carton.
Well, on the carton
it says why they--
Ben and Jerry-- hooked up.
And I'm close with
Ben and Jerry.
So we made that union
a long time ago.
But they do say why they hooked
up with Greyston, and
what's going on.
So once a year there's
this mandala day.
And one year at the mandala day,
the folks made a mural, a
large mural.
And on that mural, the scenes
are interconnectedness with
each other, serving
the community.
It blew me away.
If you told me that any Zen
group in the country was to
draw a mural like that,
I would be surprised.
That would be wonderful.
So here's folks that come from
either the homeless ranks or
the unemployed ranks,
or the drug.
And that's what they
came up with.
And they came up with three
important themes for Greyston.
They came up with it.
In the Zen Peacemakers we
have three tenets--
approaching something without
attachment to your ideas,
being totally open and
deep listening.
And second, bearing witness,
trying to remove the
dichotomy, the dualist way of
thinking between you and the
environment.
And third, out of that, let
loving actions arise.
So my opinion is that loving
actions will arise.
They came up with
three things.
The first being, listen
to others.
The second is, essentially,
bearing witness.
Feel how the others
are acting.
And the third is serve
the community.
I think, for me, the connection
more than clear.
They wouldn't call it
Buddhist or Zen.
But that's something that
they would not have said
20, 30 years ago.
Most of them are not
there 20, 30 years.
It's sort of common.
I knew Jonas Salk.
And he says, Zen will work
because it's like any cell.
It's biology.
You put a healthy cell into
a sick situation.
If the cell is really healthy,
it will replicate.
And the system will
become healthy.
For me, what's happened at
Greyston is a proof of that.
Not so easy to insert healthy
cells in different places.
But it's possible.
Everything's possible.
AUDIENCE: What do you think is
the largest impediment to our
society being more Zen-like
and understanding Zen.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Being human.
I work in so many parts
of this world.
I think it's, in some way,
always been the same.
People ask me, is it
getting better?
Is it getting worse?
And I think, in some sense,
it's useless question.
It's what am I going
to do now?
What am I going to do?
Not whether the system's getting
better or worse.
What am I going to do?
That's the only thing I
can get hooked into.
I don't know if it's getting
better or worse.
We worked for so long
in the Middle East.
If you want to work in
frustrating places, that can
be very frustrating.
Part of me would say, I
can't do that anymore.
And then the other part would
say, what are you doing
quitting, man.
Just do your best.
The issue is not to have
any expectations.
If you have any expectations,
you'll have frustrations.
You set goals.
And you work for them.
But don't expect anything
to come of them.
You just do all the work.
You just work with them.
AUDIENCE: But isn't part
of setting goals having
expectations?
BERNIE GLASSMAN:
No, not to me.
You could define it that way.
So you've got to define
the words.
For me, when I started working
in Yonkers, I said my goal was
I want to end homelessness.
I didn't think I was going
to end homelessness.
But that gave me a direction
to steer to.
This is what I want to
work to do, man.
And I'll do my best I can.
And if I don't eliminate
homelessness,
I won't fall apart.
If I had an expectation, then
I would probably feel, I
screwed up.
I didn't do what I had
expected to do.
In the meantime,
you did a lot.
I look at those goals as
points to navigate to.
But the important thing is the
road you're on, and what
you're doing on that, how you're
walking that road.
There's where I'm going.
And maybe I'll make it.
Maybe I won't.
And maybe the point
will change.
By the time I get here or here,
I'll think differently.
That's the other thing.
A Buddhist opinion is that
everything has changed.
Nothing stays the same, even
one's idea of the goal.
That won't change.
AUDIENCE: Did you speak with the
Coen brothers about your
perspective, and to
Jeff Bridges?
Did they have any of the
same beliefs going
into the script writing?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: I actually
did speak with the Coen
brothers way before we were
going to do the book.
And one of them said that
he knew about Zen.
But he had no Zen influence
on the script.
And the other one said he knew
nothing about Zen, and wasn't
interested in knowing
anything about it.
But before we did the book, Jeff
Bridges actually called
them to get an OK from them.
He said Bernie and I are
going to do this book.
And his language is, I don't
want to piss on your carpet.
So how do you feel about that?
And they said, go for it, man.
It sounds great.
But they do they had
no Buddhist--
AUDIENCE: You had no involvement
in the movie?
Your involvement came later.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: A year after I
saw the movie is when I met
Jeff, because we moved
to Santa Barbara,
where he was living.
And we met, and not because
of the movie.
We met for other reasons.
His wife is very involved
in homeless work.
And he was a high school buddy
of a woman I know pretty well
whose name is Bonnie Raitt.
And she suggested
I meet with him.
AUDIENCE: One of the things you
said repeatedly about how
Zen is about losing this
separation between yourself
and the rest of the world--
or life you said.
When you say life, do
you mean everything?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Everything.
AUDIENCE: --a special?
BERNIE GLASSMAN:
No, everything.
AUDIENCE: It reminds me of
something I've heard of a
number of times.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Let me
backtrack for one second.
It's not between losing the
sense of yourself and
everything.
What you gain is the experience
of yourself as
everything.
Because if it's all
interconnected, it's all one.
You can't be talking about the
self and something outside.
You know set theory.
You draw a circle.
You can't have an outside
to the circle if the
circle is the self.
AUDIENCE: Do you follow anything
in neuroscience and
psychology?
Because I've heard a similar
concept come up a number of
times when people talk about
the brain development.
And it's one of these
concepts.
Below a certain age, you
don't have the concept.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Jung talks
about the collective
unconsciousness.
That's the same thing,
in a sense.
There's Dalai Lama has assembled
a group that's
working, the mind-life group.
There's a lot of work going on,
nowadays, which is saying
the same thing in scientific
language.
AUDIENCE: What I've seen is
they've done experiments with
children, to try and understand
at what age and
what brain structures actually
change when children develop
this concept.
Below a certain age, they don't
have a concept of the
self versus the rest
of the world.
And is it something that
has to develop
as the brain develops?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: I
haven't kept up.
I haven't read.
There's a lot of research
going on.
But it seems to me--
the other thing that I've
learned through life is that
everything I say
is my opinion.
And people are saying
other things.
That's their opinion.
It's your opinion, man.
It's my opinion, man.
And we can share--
AUDIENCE: Is there no
objective reality?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: In my
opinion, there's
no objective reality.
In my opinion.
In my opinion, they're all
opinions that we can share.
And it's great, man.
We can share opinions, and
discuss them, and whatever.
And once we come up with the
notion of objective realities,
then we go to war.
And we get angry.
All that stuff can exist, if
we accept that it's all
different opinions,
in my opinion.
In my opinion, the brain is an
instrument, just like the
eyes, nose.
They're just instruments.
And the brain function,
the functioning of
the brain, is thinking.
And it thinks in a
dualistic way.
That's just the way it is.
It's just an instrument, man.
It's not all of us.
There are other ways of
experiencing life.
So when we experience life
using our brain, we're
generally--
like I see the sun--
the brain is saying,
that's the sun.
It gave it a label.
And then it would say,
that's a beautiful.
It's not as good as the sun.
It's not experiencing
it directly.
It's bringing up concepts.
That's the way it function.
Zen is about having an
experience that's not negating
the brain, but not through the
brain, a direct experience.
Can you imagine experiencing the
sun every day anew for the
first time?
And then later making
commentary.
AUDIENCE: The other thing
that sounds--
I'm making connections between
what you're saying and what
I've heard.
At the same time as what I said,
the brain developing and
constructing this idea of the
boundaries between me and not
me, they're finding more and
more that this concept that
there's a singular stream of
consciousness is actually the
construct of how a brain
constructs them in experience
of the world.
In fact, your brain, you can
have multiple thoughts
independently, and only
afterwards try
to intervene them.
I'm wondering if you see
everything as connected--
if everything is interrelated,
then you don't need this--
I'm sorry.
I'm not sure how it relates.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Don't
need what?
AUDIENCE: If there isn't
a singular stream of
consciousness that's you, then
you're just part of the world.
BERNIE GLASSMAN: The cosmic
consciousness.
You're part of that.
I'll give you my opinion
on all that.
Obviously--
not obviously.
In my opinion, the brain is
constantly coming up with
different thoughts, and
different ideas, and whatever.
Those, to me, are opinions.
That's one thing.
It's not going to stop.
A metaphor for the
interconnectedness of life in
Buddhism is in one of these
sutras is called Indra's net.
And it's a net that extends
throughout all space and time.
It's a pretty big net.
And at each node on the net,
there's a bright pearl.
That bright pearl represents a
particular instance of time,
time and space.
So I'm a bright pearl.
The next instant, I'm another
bright pearl.
It's all these bright pearls.
Everything, the thought of a
unicorn, that thought is a
bright pearl.
Every bright pearl is reflected
in every other
bright pearl.
And every other bright pearl
is reflected in this
background.
And if you shake the net
anywhere, the vibrations are
felt throughout the
whole thing.
So that's our metaphor for your
interconnectedness of life.
That metaphor came
up a long time.
Years later, somebody stole the
word indra-net, converted
it a little, and called
it internet.
And instead of a pearl at every
node, they put computers.
They put all kinds of things.
That's my feeling.
The energy of that
interconnectedness now is
being labelled and felt.
And I think Arab Spring
is the energy of that.
That arose without--
if you ask how did it arise,
people say, it rose because of
Facebook, whatever.
But I say that kind of energy
will keep arising in different
things, and spreading.
So Arab Spring spread to be
called different things in
different parts of the world.
And, of course, the internet
is a huge manifestation of
that kind of energy.
[INAUDIBLE]
interconnectedness.
And you guys are working on the
fact that there's so much
interconnected.
You can go from here to there,
all over the place.
At least that's my opinion.
AUDIENCE: So if you had
access to all that
interconnectedness--
BERNIE GLASSMAN: We all
have access to it.
AUDIENCE: At your disposal,
let's say.
What would be the most effective
thing you'd do to
increase the sense in which
people feel interconnected?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: Well
that's my job.
AUDIENCE: If you could
do anything
you want to the internet--
BERNIE GLASSMAN:
That's my job.
My job and the vow I made in
my job was to help people
experience the
interconnectedness of life.
So I'm constantly thinking
of how to do that.
There was a time when I was
doing that only in the venue
of a meditation hall.
That's where I worked.
And I decided that the venue
you should be the world.
So then I had to say,
what does it mean?
How do we work in businesses,
and social
engagement, and sports?
And that's a constant thing.
That's my profession, is to try
to experiment with that.
AUDIENCE: What have you found to
be the most effective ways
of getting people to feel just
a little more interconnected?
To get people started towards
feeling interconnected?
What's really worked
well for you?
BERNIE GLASSMAN: For me,
these bearing witness
retreats have been huge.
That's a huge effect on people,
when they come to
those bearing witness
retreats.
If you want to get a taste, come
to some of those bearing
witness retreats.
They're all on our websites,
zenpeacemakers.org.
But in some way that's
a little passive.
But that's the teaching.
If somebody says they want to
study what I'm doing, I say
come to a bearing witness
retreat, and you'll feel it.
And then to get deeper,
I say get involved
serving your community.
I also would encourage
meditation.
As I say, I meditate
every day.
But I also know a lot of people
that meditate every day
that I don't think are
doing more than
meditating every day.
They get relaxed.
They feel better.
I don't know if it's about
just feeling better.
OK, I think I was supposed
to end at 2:00.
Was that true?
Or it was no set?